we're going to take a little tour of
what's going on in healthcare not just
healthcare insurance industry and I'll
give you a perspective that you probably
wouldn't expect to get from a health
insurance executive but as Peter
mentioned in 1979 I had flunked out of
college for the second time with a 1.79
grade point average at Wayne State
University and I was assembling rear
axle differentials for the mercury
bobcat at Ford Motor Company and making
sixty-two thousand dollars a year and I
thought that was a pretty good job and
it was a seven-to-three shift and then
weekends and a friend of mine suggested
that I get my bachelor's degree I'm so I
went the easiest route which is
accounting because I was a math major a
friend of mine then was studying for the
GMAT and I placed in the top percentile
in the country got offers from
universities like Stanford to go to
school Cornell was the one I chose
because it was cheapest and somehow I've
ended up in the healthcare industry I've
had one resume I've never looked for a
job and every time the phone has rang
because somebody needed my help I fix
broken things and build new things I do
not make the trains run on time
that's not my specialty so my career has
been peppered with taking companies
public and selling organizations and
fixing broken companies and I don't
think that I could be better prepared at
a time like this in the health insurance
industry and the healthcare industry to
fix an industry that really is not an
industry is really not a system and
given my personal experiences we're
briefly described I've seen it work from
both sides inside and out and it really
doesn't work well and I'm here to share
with you a larger vision of what it
could be and some of our experiences
that were going through at Aetna
Aetna built this as the very first job
we're losing a million dollars a day in
2001 and people say why
raining values well we need an
organizing principle around which we can
rally 44,000 employees which was how
much money we were losing every hour
forty-four thousand dollars an hour
twenty four by seven by fifty two so it
was like every employee reaching into
the till pulling a dollar out and
burning it every hour of the day and so
we organize them around these sets of
principles which is meant to put the
people who use our services at the
center of everything we do and to
organize their thinking when there
wasn't someone around to tell them what
to do so one of the things I like to
focus on in particularly in this kind of
talk is inspiration we really do inspire
one another in what we do both
personally and professionally
we are a leed-certified organization we
have given away four hundred and twenty
five million dollars as a company
through our foundation in our history we
have over a million hours per every
three years from our employees and
voluntary service to the communities
that serve and they contribute with our
matching nine million dollars a year to
their charities across the country and
around the world and so our view is
really to inspire one another not only
in what we do and work every day but
what we do and how we represent
ourselves to the public so on this was
an article by Zeke Emanuel in the New
York Times talking about the end of
insurance companies by 2020 and I would
argue that the insurance companies that
we know today will end it'll probably be
sooner than 20 and 20 but we're not
going away so I'll paraphrase Mark Twain
who's from Hartford Connecticut where we
are headquartered you know the rumors of
our demise is greatly exaggerated number
one we have a lot of capital number two
we're in the center of all the data and
number three for those of us who think
about our role differently and are
willing to give up control to get power
we can actually have a huge influence on
healthcare here and around the world
so we've as a company been using
somebody from the Stern School at New
York University his name's Luke Williams
and he has this book called disrupt and
it's taking things that you would
normally assume are cliches about what
we do every day
and turning them on their head and the
one example he used outside of
healthcare was we all believe that socks
should be sold in pairs right we got two
feet and they should match how many
people in here have young teenage
children daughters particularly right
and what do they buy they buy little
mismatched three socks in a bunch and
they're all different and I'm kind of
jealous because I like to live wear
different colored socks and and they
don't have my size um I went and checked
but that's a great idea we challenged an
assumption that said socks always should
be sold in pairs he calls them cliches
so let me give you a few clichés about
the health insurance industry health
care costs always go up right inexorable
can't stop it healthy people are better
risk than sick people right and then
waste in health care system is
unavoidable so these are three cliches
that our team came up with and we chose
to challenge a couple of them and I'll
give you an example
Aetna has been around for 160 years we
have been assessing underwriting and
pricing risk for 160 years the formulas
we use are 160 years old I believe that
some of our actuaries started with the
company in 1851 so of course we know how
to do that what's changed over the years
what we assess underwrite and price so
here are some hypotheses what if we keep
healthcare costs flat or even lower them
what if the sickest populations were
actually the best risk and what if we
could pay for the uninsured by reducing
waste including paying back half the
u.s. 16 trillion dollars worth of debt
that are the bills of the hypotheses
that we have challenged sicker people
are better to take care of and we can
pay back half the nation's debt over the
next decade
so what we have is a convergence of a
few things all created by the Affordable
Care Act so for those of you who were
wondering why the president was focused
on the affordable care act when the
economy was headed to ruin 75 percent of
the next 10 trillion dollars worth of
debt in this nation will be driven by
Medicare and Medicaid if you add Social
Security it's a hundred and fifty
percent if we solved waste in the health
care system we would reduce the 2013
deficit which is nine hundred and ten
million dollars by eighty percent so
health care is our problem with the
economy we call them entitlements
because it sounds better when we
distance them from people but it's
really about health care so the
Affordable Care Act has created an
action-forcing event it causes people to
think differently about how we solved
the problem and based on technology
that's always been around and some huge
economic shifts that have occurred in
the health care system over the last
five to ten years we believe that the
opportunity for innovation is now so
let's talk about the economic side of
this this is the waste in the health
care system in 2009 750 billion dollars
in 2009 alone this was put together by
the Institutes of medicine so it's a
bunch of doctors it was an insurance
executive sitting around looking for a
big number
these are physicians who said that we
waste 750 billion or approximately 30
percent of healthcare spending this year
it's 2.7 trillion so call it 800 billion
dollars if we fix this problem in a
decade we pay back 8 trillion dollars
half the US deficit if we fix just half
of it we do what simpson-bowles did with
their recommendation to the President
and to Congress and we fix just 20% of
it we pay for the Affordable Care Act
without raising anyone's taxes so when
we looked at what we assess underwrite
in price this is the problem and we're
part of that problem we have 44%
inefficiently in efficient delivery of
care and unnecessary services we have
fraud waste and abuse and then we have
administrative costs all
my system that tries to tracked each
individual use 20% 25% of that is
insurance administrative cost hospital
physician and other administrative costs
so what do we do to make the system
better well we have the technology today
and I'll talk about that in a few
minutes here's the other shift now for
all of you who worry about seeing a
foreign medical grad as a physician your
worries are about to be over because
they're not going to stay here anymore
they'll get educated here but they're
going to go back to their countries
China is a hundred and sixty thousand
physician short will be a hundred
thousand physicians short India is short
of physicians everywhere around the
world is short of physicians and as
those economies emerge and create middle
classes that have higher expectations
around social safety nuts they're going
to be able to afford to keep those
physicians and we won't have them and
we'll have an even bigger shortage
secondly physicians the economics of
independent physician practice are
broken insurance companies run on
underwriting margin hospitals run on
revenue and doctors offices run on cash
and if you've ever run a cash business
when you're trying to take risk it blows
up on you and you go out of business so
over the last seven to ten years
physicians have gone from 25%
institution alone to over 70%
institutional owned if you run this
number out another three years it's
going to be 85% of all the practices in
the United States and over two-thirds of
all the physicians in the United States
will be working in an institutional
setting the second thing that's
happening which is very interesting is
that a lot of these institutional
settings are now being run by physicians
so there's a fundamental shift in the
way they think about how to run the
health care system and then here is a
graph of the single largest tax increase
on the American public in the history of
the United States the
bars on the bottom are the underpayment
by the government for Medicare and
Medicaid if you look at that number it's
way off in 2009 and 2010 is going even
further with the most recent budget
proposal in reducing Medicare and
Medicaid reimbursement at the states and
who is paid for that you through your
commercial premiums at your employed
workplace or if you're lucky enough to
be in the individual insurance market
through your individual insurance
payments because in the commercial
marketplace today the average margin now
this one big assumption this assumes
that the healthcare system costs are
appropriate big assumption but just work
with me on this in the commercial market
it's a hundred and forty percent so
there's a 40 percent margin in the
commercial market from hospitals and
doctors to cover the underpayment of the
government system that is a tax that's
cost shift but it's a tax increase
because the government is under paying
and you're turning around and paying
that and covering that expense the
hospitals have figured out that what
happens when you keep doing this at
least the forward-thinking hospitals so
if you keep running this line out long
enough what also is happening is that
more people are going in government
programs Medicare and Medicaid a hundred
thousand people every day retiring so if
you keep running that out and you don't
do something about it all of a sudden
you're getting paid solely by the
government you're getting paid way under
your cost structure so let's talk about
the technology side the technology side
hit me really hard one day when I was
standing at Macy's in New York because
my daughter who is an editor at Gawker
in New York and sends me an apology
every time they write about me secretly
when she said I had to have this sweater
and here's it's at Macy's on this rack
in this department so I took out my
droid and I barcode scanned it and up
pop Google Shopper and it said here's
who made it and here's how much it costs
and then it told me
all the other stories near me that had
it and I picked the cheapest one and uh
perkupp Google Maps and I got directions
plus a phone number that I could call
and have them hold it for me and it all
took 45 seconds so I bought two sweaters
one for my daughter and the other one I
brought to work and I started showing
everybody at work we need this for
health care so the technology I'm about
to talk about isn't the genetic stuff
for all the body devices implants and
everything we can do and I can spend
time talking about that in the Q&A we're
working with all of those I'm going to
talk about the very simplest technology
that we have available and every other
aspect of our life why shouldn't the
healthcare system work for us why
shouldn't we manage our healthcare
versus having to use the healthcare
system so here are some of the Internet
and mobile adoption uses around the
United States I just returned from China
where we've done a joint venture and
I'll talk about that in a minute with
the Binhai new area in Tianjin and in
China they have 600 mobile phones 600
mobile phones in the marketplace these
are just smart phone subscribers 270
million almost as many people's are in
the United States so this adoption is
dramatically increasing everywhere
around the world and our problem here in
the United States is that every time we
build an app for the healthcare system
we have to force our members to use it
because they want to use the phone and
it's like everybody checks out when they
enter the healthcare system and puts all
their technology away and you know and
and and wanders around the system like
the walking dead and what we're finding
in places like China and in India all
people have our smart phones and mobile
phones and so you don't have to
re-educate people about how to use them
because that's all they use that's how
they access the system today Aetna for
the last seven years has been buying
technology and every time we buy them
the analysts say what are you doing why
are you wasting your time on stuff like
this well today we now have the single
bass
and the only full technology stack that
allows us to create what I call health
plan in a box we put hospitals and
health systems in our business so we
call bought a company called medicinal
thin firm ation exchange now has twenty
nine point eight percent of the u.s.
marketplace wired together they have a
grid technology called INEX
which shares the computing power of the
grid were real-time node encrypted so
each device is a node and we now have an
SDK software development kit and ap is
on a public website for everyone to
write apps which can be downloaded from
the INEX platform to physician and
hospital's desktops to get healthcare
technology much cheaper than they get it
from their legacy vendors today all in
its have to disrupt or underpriced that
marketplace we have active health was
the clinical decision support system
iTriage which is the device that you
will now be able to use in the
healthcare system to get that office
visit an appointment whenever you want
care pass which connects across the
platform all of your apps that you use
for healthcare fitbit your running
program your dietary program all into
one application that shares the data all
connected to our own intellectual
property what have we done 40 systems
around the United States are either in
Leonard time or contracting with us to
put this technology stack in to connect
them with their with their doctors and
with every other hospital they do
business with to create an insurance
mechanism to manage risk and what we
become is sort of the intelligence
inside their organizations to be able to
power their systems and give them the
intellectual property to manage that
risk we have made it payer agnostic they
can use it for all of our competitors
and we allow them to white label it and
put their own products in the
marketplace in the end when public
exchanges come up and we can expect them
some in 2014 but it's going to roll out
over a number of years we would rather
have Banner Health System and their
product on the exchange than Aetna
banner power by medicinal Innova power
by active health because we redefine
keeping my doctor and my hospital and so
it becomes a really a different kind of
health care system and all we are is the
intellectual property inside the system
helping the management using our risk
base capital to help support their
overall risk management so this is a
very different role for an insurance
company
we don't sell members anymore we convert
patients and by the way the sick ones
are the most profitable so if you think
this conversation is strange have it
with all your actuaries sitting in the
room there going wait a minute you want
us to under we want the sick ones we
want to be the bad Bank because if we
get paid for the risk we can manage it
more effectively using this technology
so imagine a world where payers manage
health instead of risk because risk is
sort of second nature to us and so this
is our model go back to the 70s if any
of you can remember those bell-bottoms
right long hair little skinny glasses
and we used to have people back then
called health systems planners and
health systems planners used to look at
the demography the disease burden in the
economic and environmental and societal
trends and they used to decide whether
or not a hospital could buy a new piece
of technology it was called certificate
of need but we decided that was just too
much of a hassle and a waste in the
system so we got rid of all of our
health systems planners we sent them off
somewhere they became Hospital strategic
planners and what we did is we lost our
opportunity to do true population health
management so what if we actually looked
at the demography disease burden the
economic societal cultural trends of a
community and said where should our
hospitals be where should our practices
be what kind of doctors clinicians nurse
practitioners massage therapists
acupuncturist should we have in the
system all of the goal of improving the
productivity of the population allowing
them to be more economically viable and
happy as a definition for health so
that's what this is now this will happen
soon but not here in the United States
this is a shot I turn from a card three
weeks ago this is the Binhai new area of
Tianjin China where this is one of six
different pods of 20 to 30 skyscrapers
all 50 to 100 stories all going up at
the same time they're all empty Gigi's
keep driving around they planted 373
million new mature trees to improve the
environment and it looks a bit like
Manhattan when you get close enough to
it because they want it to be China's
Silicon Valley and they want to attract
four and a half to six million
multinationals to this community and
they want to have a healthcare system
for the future
now why do they need a healthcare system
well China savings rates 50% a third of
which goes to first out for education
because education ends early second to
health care because they only cover 240
RMB which is 40 US dollars and
healthcare everybody's insured up to 240
US dollars and then thirdly for housing
and with 53% of the population now in
cities their imports required to support
that population our overwhelming their
exports and so they need to create as
part of the 12th five-year plan a
inclusive economy focused on moderate
prosperity or a domestic economy and the
only way to do that is to reduce the
savings right and the only way to reduce
the savings rate is to create a safety
net in health care and education and oh
by the way if the health care system
were designed properly it could be an
economic engine that improves the
productivity financial viability creates
a service industry low carbon footprint
that could then support their domestic
economy that's what they want
we signed a joint venture deal with T
and Gen hi check last three weeks ago
March 25th
helped them build that healthcare system
as a future as a pilot so they can
consider it for the rest of the China it
will be the largest system healthcare
systems project China's ever invested in
300 million RMB and so this model is
really built around that population
health management model I showed you
creating a happier population now it's
not all altruistic it's a political
problem for them as well unless they get
this problem solved and what they don't
want is the finance minister told me in
my one of my meetings with him was we do
not want the US healthcare system
because in 40 years we can't afford it
now China little known to most people
will have more people as a percentage of
the population over 65 by 2030 than any
other country in the world will be 29%
Germany's eyes 427 percent currently
they have ninety seven point five
million diabetics we have 27 million in
the United States so they already have
this problem they just don't know it and
quite frankly people just don't get the
care one of our hottest selling products
in China is for the high net worth
individuals to be evacuated out of China
for tertiary and quarternary care they
will pay anything for that policy so
this is where the future is going to
start and as I like to say we think
about the States and here in the US as
the laboratory for democracy the
laboratory for the new health care
system is going to happen in places like
China in India
Riyadh Qatar all places where we're
talking about this kind of project as a
company not insurance
we're not underwriting anything here
we're building a healthcare system that
can be underwritten when the middle
class gets to a point where we have
enough economic personal disposable
income for them to buy insurance and how
about a world where the sick can find
the care they need in the palm of their
hand so we bought this company called
iTriage and it's free you can download
it and we've had over nine million
downloads it has a symptom checker you
can get appointments with your provider
you can send them your health data out
of your personal health record and you
can get follow-ups from the physician
and
we'll have here in another month or so
when we launch is the ability to buy
care on the spot market basis that's
vacant near you think of it as open
table for health care lab tests x-rays
flu shots office visits and we'll buy it
and then we'll resell it for convenience
so what we want to do with this piece of
technology is want to redefine quality
as convenience because for most people
that use the healthcare system today one
of the biggest compliance issues is it's
too hard to get it done I've got to work
my life around the healthcare system
instead of taking care of my health on
my terms and this piece of technology is
going to do that so our whole move is to
make it easier and as one of your
professors BJ Fogg here at Stanford has
talked about is you know you need to
make it easier you don't have to compel
people and I can have a conversation
with any one of you about diabeetus and
what it will do to you if you keep
eating and living the lifestyle you're
living and we can talk about what that
means for you when you're 30 years old
or and when I talk to even people in
their 20s they go yeah yeah that's great
mañana but if we make it easy to do we
can have an impact things like my my top
band that I'm wearing and so that gets
connected to how about a world where
healthy comanded where the healthy can
manage their wellness in health in one
spot
and so we'll launch as well care pass
which will connect all of your apps to
one's data set so when you update one
piece of data and any of your other apps
and updates the rest of your apps again
easy so that you can track it so this is
the future of health care where the
consumer takes control of the healthcare
system not the insurance company not the
hospital not the doctor oh that will be
the difference where you are in charge
of your health versus trying to make the
health care system work for you and none
of it is bleeding edge technology right
none of it
so it's really about mass customization
for the individual using population
health making people more economically
viable and happier excuse me
so the healthcare system is going to
change because the Affordable Care Act
has created an action-forcing event in
October of 2013 all the fundamentals of
the health insurance industry will
change that will ripple through the
healthcare system
doctors hospitals patients and it will
all be up for grabs as I said to our
team we have three hundred full-time
equivalents working on this everyday
inside our organization we took our
brightest people and put them in a in a
project management office they said to
them we need to be compliant with the
new law but we've got to find all the
ponies in that stuff because there's
going to be bunches of ponies and when
people fail we want to be on the other
end of it to consolidate and make the
system better so the Affordable Care Act
is driving this the system will change
it's really about the consumer and their
own access to the healthcare system
managing their health versus managing
their health care and we believe that
will be a key part of this but in a
fundamentally different way as an
organization and by the way as a final
point the healthcare cost problem is a
major problem in every country around
the world regardless who pays for it
what's going on in Western Europe and
southern Europe is a fight over the
social contract that people thought they
had after World War two that is no
longer affordable and their governments
are paying for it and what's going on in
the Middle East and China is a stunning
fear on their part that they're going to
end up with what we've got in the
developed countries so everybody's
looking at this issue everybody's
focused on it and I think the
opportunity is here in large part
because of a simple act that was patched
and passed in March of 2010 so thank you
very much for your time and attention
I'll take any questions that you may
have
we have microphones up here and being
from Detroit I cannot be intimidated or
insulted so any question is a good one
could you comment on care seniors in the
last year of life as well as very health
issues so on July 15th 2002 I put my son
into hospice me a t-cell gamma-delta
lymphoma that was considered incurable
and I had lived with him for a year and
a half in the hospital trying to fix it
and in order to do that I had to admit
he was going to die in six months and
that I could no longer see curative
services well we found a drug in Europe
to help feed him he was starving from
his cure and we actually he graduated
from hospice and he's now a quant at
State Street financial advisors in
Boston and living a very good life he
was the recipient of that kidney I gave
away in 2007 and we get together on
Sunday evenings and get the kidneys back
together and drink blood long necks when
I got back to work we changed our
end-of-life program now what we sad was
we are no longer to make you admit
you're going to die in six months and
we're going to allow you to see curative
services even while you're in a hospice
and because we're afraid of what that
would do to our cost we did it with our
cell phone and clients you know let
Mikey try it right and we did it with
our cell phone and clients and we were
stunned with the results eighty nine
percent drop in acute days seventy nine
percent drop in in in procedures and 80
percent drop in costs and feedback from
our customers from our members that was
just incredible and so now we all of our
clients got it we think that ought to be
the standard across the United States
now we introduced it to the White House
during the healthcare reform debate and
they wouldn't touch it because of death
committees right death panels and so we
brought it to IOM and said why don't you
hold up conference we held the compris
and we haven't made much progress
because I think people are afraid to
touch it because of the political
realities but we think that's the way to
move forward it's easier for people to
do
yes thank you for your time I do
research in BJ's lab here and sometimes
get to work with your Etna folks so I'm
thrilled to listen to you so a lot of
what you talked about is really exciting
and also heavily dependent on healthcare
consumerism here in the United States
and we've been receiving our health care
through employers since World War two
and so they're shipped to healthcare
consumerism is what culturally we're
hoping for I was wondering if you could
comment on that and talk about what
Aetna and other payers are doing about
that the shift to healthcare consumerism
is unstoppable and inexorable for a
couple of reasons one is that employers
have been shifting 50% of the increase
in healthcare costs to their employees
each year for the last seven years and
so if you keep that trend going for
another five employees we'll be paying
half of their health care either through
out-of-pocket costs on benefits or
insurance shared insurance premiums and
so when that happens they're going to
say well what are you guys doing for me
on trend right and and so we believe
it's inexorable the second thing that's
going to happen is that the public
exchanges have now freed the minds of
health insurance executives around the
country to build private exchanges and
what private exchanges will do is create
marketplaces for individuals that allow
them to get a value equation on benefits
that matches their personal lifestyle so
there'll be more offerings and because
there will be more offerings they'll be
able to select with selection tools that
we built and tested and actually the
overall pools risk goes down because
people are not under insured or over
insured they're insured just right for
what they expect for their families so
it's going to be a consumer marketplace
even though the employers may be
involved but I think evolution
evolutionary over time they'll actually
sort of disappear and move the defined
contribution and also go so it's it's
going to happen it's here we believe
it's here it's just early in the game
but you can never get too early get
started too early on the change mmm yes
hi mark sitter I appreciate your
comments and support of everything
you're doing
I might concern in terms of health care
costs going up
the biggest chunk of it and the
fastest-growing and probably the place
we greatest waste is hospitals and it's
hard to be much of a consumer in the
hospital side Aetna good example your
you know your typical at seven eight
nine percent market share in any local
area and it's very local issue so how
can either the insurance industry or
consumers really make a dent and what is
the biggest and fastest growing part of
the costs so the consolidation you're
seeing that showed on that slide
consolidation with physicians is also
happening between hospitals and systems
are getting larger and so the model of
what I call mutually assured destruction
which is when we beat each other up in
the marketplace until somebody loses or
gives up or gets tired won't work
because the people to get lost in the
middle of that are the consumers the
people are using the healthcare system
so we need to fundamentally change our
relationship and so our model of
infusing our technology and capabilities
into their own running of the system
will cause them to change that and the
systems that are forward thinking we've
selected the systems we're working with
very carefully to make sure that we have
people that will get it right so that we
create okay I want one of those too over
time now the thing that I don't talk
about often is the ugly problem that's
going to happen five to ten years from
now and that is you know we used in
Michigan where I grew up he's to get
water in the basement in the spring when
it would rain and so you go downstairs I
got three feet of water in the basement
that wasn't bad it was when the water
went away that you had this horrible
problem but you had to clean up well
when we get through this shift there
will be all this stuff we have left that
we won't know what to do with capacity
you know I go up to Blue Hill Maine
every summer the Blue Hill hospital I
mean I can't imagine what goes on in
that place and why it's still there but
they the people in that community love
it but that place isn't going to survive
and so there going to be a bunch of
places and things and technologies and
doctors particularly specialists that we
are going to need anymore how do we best
use them well in emerging countries like
China they are doing everything you can
get to get primary and secondary care
systems up cordon Airy tertiary care
systems are way to a bridge too far for
them anytime soon so the potential to
export our expertise through technology
and other means is going to make a big
difference
or to get the people here for care so I
think that's going to be how we're going
to manage it but that's stuff all that
stuff laying around going to be the big
problem and I think that's where we're
going to see the big public problem and
I think we saw that in UK a few years
ago when they try to shut down some
hospitals as part of their health reform
effort I can relate to your comments
about the upcoming physician shortage
because I was appalled to find that my
medical school that I guarded at 40
years ago the size of the entering class
has not changed in 40 years um so my
question for you is can you comment on
the article that was in the Atlantic
recently the robot will see you now
about the coming presence of robots and
also about the the model where the
decision-making is ratcheted down and
that the physicians are the ones just
supervising ancillary healthcare
personnel so I think the second part is
probably the more realistic than the
robot but you know robots sell magazines
right and and so you know I think the
real issue is going to be a new model of
healthcare today in a physician's office
the staff works to support the physician
and taking care of the patient in a new
model called patient-centered medical
homes the staff all focuses on the
patient and where you have your clinical
nurse practitioners you know
cranial-sacral therapists acupuncturist
who all do their own thing and that the
physicians use of skills is for the far
more cognitive laying out of hands kind
of things and when's the last time
anybody's been to a doctor the doctor
actually touched you right I mean I have
a spinal cord injury and every time I go
see a doctor for follow-up in evaluation
show you I saw your films and I looked
at your stuff I don't need to examine
you so I think the whole shift and the
way we treat people in the doctor's
office has to happen it's going to be
this patient-centered medical home and
it's gonna be driven by the shortage
because we can't nearly educate enough
doctors and the time it's going to take
to get them to meet that shortage yes
sir
yeah thanks for your comments specific
question so policy limits the removal of
policy limits do one of the key
functions be POC I'm sure it's kept your
actuaries thinking a little bit about
the implications I'm curious about the
implications you think as a major
don't insure in terms of the removal of
annual and lifetime limits and
specifically the experience you have in
social media last year on the student
health yeah with our G the on the on the
first part of the question
you know nasty little secret it didn't
cost that much true right so it's been
no big deal you know I mean we when you
put it over a broader population the
cost really isn't there so I think we
didn't see the kind of impact we thought
we would saw would see and quite frankly
it's been pretty good now utilization is
really low right now because of the
economy because what people are paying
out-of-pocket so I think we have an
artificial environment an artifact of
people not using as much cure as they
otherwise would which so far we think is
a good thing because we're not seeing
people avoid chronic care that they need
we're seeing people not getting an
antibiotic for a cold which is all good
stuff so people aren't hitting those
policy limits the second one on social
media so one of my goals in this job and
CEOs are fleeting I'm the 14th chairman
of a hundred and sixty year old company
and we have a very short half-life the
first chairman was around for 20 years
and now we usually last five or six
years now but one of my goals is to
reestablish the credibility of corporate
leadership in the eyes of the American
public really tall task the only way you
do that is make yourself available as my
PR folks over there will tell you I tell
them they can prepare me they can't
protect me I'm going out there so I was
out on Twitter and and you know I got
engaged with this patient it was a
student he was you know his late 20s he
got colon cancer and he had a policy
that the universities sold that was
really cheap at three hundred thousand
dollar limit so as a student you think
you know what are the chances I'm going
to hit three hundred thousand dollars
worth of healthcare well he got Stage
four colon cancer and he was well
through it so he tweeted me and said I'm
a hundred and eighteen thousand dollars
over why don't you write a cheque given
that you made nine point seven five
million dollars last year and I engaged
him and you know when I engaged him all
of his friends piled on and I was in
this very intense conversation for about
twelve hours while my team I have a
bunch of Twitter reps
work with me now that follow up behind
me they were working out our arrangement
with the school to try and get this kid
more coverage and so we saw what we
found out was there was five other
students that hit the same problem
they weren't now all colon cancer but
they were hitting their limits at the
same University
right and so what we did is we had the
university pay op premium for each of
those six people to a five hundred
thousand dollar limit and then we
renewed them at a million dollar limit
the next year and then of course when
the Affordable Care Act kicked in there
was no limit and we were able to get
them covered and we got it all paid now
our eg just passed away two weeks ago on
the end of March because he was pretty
advanced in his cancer but that is just
a typical problem that I deal with a
dozen of those every day not as big a
case but cases now that reach out to me
and want me to help and we solve most of
those problems and we also say no to
some people who have you know
expectations beyond it now where's this
all headed I would argue that if we do
population health management right we
don't need benefit plans now you have
one of those here in California it's
called the scan health plan down in San
Diego and it's called a social HMO where
we provide all the benefits necessary to
keep people healthy follow-up cab ride
to the office after a discharge from
suggestive heart failure you know
diapers from others of three who can't
afford them all toward making this
investment in keeping people healthy so
if we make that leap and I may either be
on the beach or taking a dirt nap by the
time we get there but that is sort of
the evolution we need to move to where
the the community gets together and say
this is what we should provide in the
way of services to people to keep them
healthy yes so I look at things from a
little different perspective that's how
you add the liability factored into the
conversation and are you and what weight
do you put to that when you speak to for
instance the the nurses or staff taking
care of a patient instead of the
physician and then some of these
personalized apps I wonder how that's
being factored in from your perspective
well you know on the latter part on the
apps we do spend more time
with the FDA then we would like and we
try to stay this side of having to be
regulated as a medical device but we're
getting closer with each evolution that
we make and so we know where that line
is and we're trying to stay on this side
of it but I think we'll eventually have
to cross it and you know we're working
with companies like Medtronic to connect
to their pacemakers to follow
arrhythmias and to report those into our
clinical decision support systems and
get the information to the doctor before
the patient even knows they've got a
problem and all that's going to drag us
into the FDA compliance problem and
we'll have to get approved so we're not
quite there yet but we're on this side
of it and the liability side of things
you know we are we've been dealing with
liability and we have a list that would
probably impress you of cases going on
in any given day and I think what we
handle those well and part of handling
it well is really to be very honest with
the people we're dealing with and be
very transparent about what they're
getting in that getting and I think that
works in the practice setting as well
because people often don't get explained
what's going on they don't get the right
set of information to make good
decisions and they have different
expectations and they should have and
want to blame somebody they get angry
and and you know I'm probably abnormal I
worry less about malpractice liability
as a driver of healthcare costs then all
those other things up on that list and
so we could solve those you know we can
then get at malpractice side but all
those other things I had on that circle
of 750 billion are far more significant
than malpractice right now okay as we
move from volume based care to
value-based care how do we really
measure the quality of care and who is
the arbiter of that quality so the
quality of care is gonna be in the eyes
of the person receiving the care but
when I broke my neck I have severe
neuropathy my left arm feels like it's
burning on fire all day long even at
this moment and the only way and when I
was given seven different narcotics and
I walked around like Charlie Brown in
the peanuts commercial you know when his
mother would talk
while the whole world sounded like that
to me and I knew I wasn't going to be a
highly functioning human being I went
and got cranial sacral therapy
acupuncture I carry my own needles now
and do it myself and I use yoga and
meditation to manage my pain every day I
take no pain medication now that is
outside the norm of what we would call
healthcare right and but for me that's
what makes me healthy and so I think
this definition of I decide what's
healthy for me versus what some
arbitrary set of metrics decides what's
healthy is the most important thing and
so getting that into people's hands and
allowing them to make that decision will
make them happier and healthier now how
do we pay for that and I think we need
to and so back to my number of you know
what if we just said no more increase in
health care across what have we said 2.7
trillion is enough all you figure out
how to spend that differently I think we
could do that
we've got governance issues and a whole
bunch of other issues but I think we
could figure out how to do it
differently if we just kept the budget
flat and so I think it's that's moving
it to outcomes based our people
healthier are they happier we should
actually measure people's happiness with
the healthcare system everybody loves
their own insurance company but hates
insurance companies interestingly enough
and so I think this this notion of I
feel healthy and I'm and I'm happier as
a result of it and I'm productive and I
have economic sustainability because of
that productivity should be the
definition of it long way to go but
that's where we ultimately need to head
yes sir thank you Mark
in this inevitable world of consumerism
in every every other aspect of being a
consumer price transparency is a
foundation it's a fundamental can you
talk about what you see that as the role
of a price transparency in particular
what that is doing to support it both
internally and in support of others who
are trying to pursue so we have the top
30 prices of what we pay to every
provider in the United States on our
website for any member who wants to look
at it less than 10 percent
we have a member payment estimator tool
that allows you to auto adjudicate your
claim on your smartphone at the doctor's
desk and settle up with your provider
less than 10 percent use it so it's
something fundamentally wrong with
people's so this care pass platform is
really about changing that where I go to
a place where the ecosystem supports me
and interacting with the healthcare
system versus having to go to this app
to find my doctor this have to find out
how much it's going to cost this app to
pay for it
it needs to be in a common eco system
like that Google shopping experience
where Google Shopper popped up and then
Google Maps popped up all at once
without me having to do it and so I
think that is where we need to go next
in order to get it done transparency
will be critically important and people
are more and more asking for it right
now we're all over the map from a
transparency standpoint at Aetna we have
the real prices we pay absent the
benefit determination which we can now
do as well but there are reference based
pricing which I don't think works really
well and people don't people sort of
look past it but as their pull more out
of their pocket they're going to they're
going to start asking that question the
best thing to do is move away from that
model a fee-for-service to bundle
payments and I think that'll be the
stuff that will make that transparency
go away or that issue anyway yes that
actually leads quite nicely into my
question which is we're focusing on you
know if if consumerism and healthcare is
isn't is a wave of the future it could
be argued that over treatment and over
utilization could be somewhat driven by
this consumer demand of healthcare
services and a lot of that demand is
sometimes supplied or driven by
physician decision-making this needs to
happen this test needs to be assigned
which could be considered one of the
reasons for rising costs so what role do
you think physician payment incentive
models and what role does Aetna play and
driving physician behavior and decision
making a few J so I think it matters and
I think the the the juxtaposition of
member out of pocket physician
reimbursement and the medical management
model which includes transparency and
advice and all those other sorts of
things is going to really create a
behavior change but it needs again to be
simple it needs to be like falling out
of bed and
and so you know I think that model is
where we need to go but I don't hear
hears them here's the problem I was if
you if I agreed that I was going to pay
90% of your next car what kind of car
would you go you get a car ten times the
amount you could afford to pay for a car
right that's the economic principle
that's the problem we have in the health
care system if I only have to pay ten
percent of my costs than anything that I
can afford up to that ten percent the
ninety percent somebody else's nickel
I'm okay with that and so I think the
shift in benefits is going to create a
change but it really needs to be
informed by data and it needs to be
simple to god I think ultimately what I
would I would argue and what we're doing
with some of our major health systems is
creating budgets and saying here's what
we think health care costs on average
across the population should be we'll
take half the risk you take half the
risk and we'll give you all the
technology to do that that's what we're
doing we actually have some health
systems that are saying we'll take 80%
of the risk because we so much believe
in our ability to better manage better
governance and better manage our
population that we will take 80% of it
and they're winning so far Thanks hi hi
mark um I guess this is the last
question my question for you is around
how do you create a more educated
consumer in a marketplace where they're
going to be directing their their health
care decisions specifically in terms of
the level of care and in terms of the
site of care so they utilize the system
appropriately so I you know I think
trying to educate everybody on how the
health care system works in a level of
detail isn't going to work sorry to say
and and the reason is is that unless the
amount of information I can gather is
immediately available and that when I
act on it it has an immediate response
I'm not going to pay attention to it
let's look at my favorite topic obesity
right mmm
sixty-two percent of the American public
is overweight you know more than a third
third of the American public is obese
and in our population of you know thirty
seven and a half million people that we
manage thirty-four percent have a
chronic disease
which drives 75% of our healthcare
spending and all those people that have
a chronic disease more than half of it
is ways related to their body weight so
in 2009 we spent billions of dollars in
this country to prevent the swine flu
from killing 10,000 people and we lose
that many people a week to obesity now
if I were to have that conversation and
say you know put the cookie down because
25 or 30 years from now you're going to
have metabolic syndrome which is highly
correlated to waist size and to fasting
glucose and that means you can have a
60% chance of being diabetic which is
going to cost you money dramatically
impact your lifestyle caused you to
maybe lose sexual function and a whole
bunch of other things limbs and you
ought to be worried about that right now
people yannick are you done yet because
I got you know I got a party to go to
and so I think that is our problem and
that is the biggest single because it is
a pandemic across the United States this
disease and it's a pandemic around the
world and we're and we're not doing that
China Saudi Arabia has the highest
incidence of diabetes of any population
in the world and you know why 50 years
ago they found oil and being overweight
and having somebody else do your work
and eating really good food was a sign
of wealth and when I talked to one of
our partners from the Oh Leone group in
in Riyadh about why is this happening
she said mark two generations ago my
grandfather was a bedouin tribal leader
starving in the desert and now we've
arrived with the highest diabetes burden
in the world so I think that so so
health education on those issues aren't
going to work we need to make it real
easy for people to stay fit so I've got
my you know my up band and I put it on
February 7th I've lost 15 pounds since
then because I'm a data geek and I look
at it all day long how many calories
have I consumed how many of I need to go
for a walk instead of that last glass of
scotch I'll go for a walk
and that's what people need to see needs
to be immediate it happens now and
you're interacting with it now thank you
so very much for your time and attention